[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
as I'm saying this we are firmly in
chapter 2 and soon the first story-based
live event is about to happen we've
already seen Travis Scott blow our minds
so I thought now is the time to bring
back a year old popular video format
nobody uses anymore a good old tear list
to determine which is the greatest live
event ever seen in fortnight I've
written down all the events in the
description below so you can copy and
paste it into the comments and fill it
in as we go let's rank everything we've
seen in chapter 1 so sit your butt down
for 10 minutes [ __ ] code atom arrow in
the star to support this madness and
let's do this
all for tonight live events ranked I've
decided to do this in chronological
order I'm using my old story video for
help so I'll link it if you need a
refresher so all the way back to season
zero we go for the first ever live event
ok nothing happened in season zero and
nothing happened in season 1 and nothing
happened in season 2 so let's go all the
way back to season 3 and March 2018 more
than two years ago this game has
legitimately taken over all our lives
the main role I need you to keep in your
mind is a live event is something that
must happen in game whilst we are
playing so for tonight's cinematics and
trailers they do not count and neither
do weekly updates when we log back into
the game and everything has changed
because if we include that there's only
one winner here
[Music]
the first live event can you remember
what it is this may shock you
the first in-game live-action event were
actually the meteorites crashing down
during matches there was no build-up no
countdown other than the asteroid
floating in the sky above the mini
meteors didn't actually hurt players
when they hit them his zach yet in hit
square in the face by one but they were
capable of destroying buildings and
could impact our fights it was a tiny
start for live event small and simple
now where would you place this on our
list it was great at the time so unique
I'd never experienced something like
that in a multiplayer game before but
looking back now it seems a little lame
I think I'm gonna throw this as a seat
great good but not great but these
falling balls of rock set up so much
more including the first real
substantial live event the rocket event
of season 4 let's set the scene over two
months of in game update saw the visitor
revealed who found a secret villains
lair in the mountains and began to craft
a rocket to go home when the countdown
began we all jumped into game to see a
simple rocket launch well things went so
very wrong the visitors mode of
transport malfunctioned and opened up
cracks in space and time I remember
being in game and completely blown away
by this cracks in the very dome we
played in also I love the way the
crashed fuel pod impacted the world -
smashing a farm building or - so they
should get extra points so now we have
to get this on our chart where would you
be putting this a2e a being great he
being poor you see I'm thinking b-but I
need to commit this is tough as I say
this was an awesome build-up and the
event impacted the island and set up the
entire storyline of bot night the way we
know it now it's got to be 80 and I'm
putting this in the a rack if you can
remember that far back how great was it
to be in-game at that moment this
started the hype and made fortnight the
global force it is yeah I'm sticking
with a this is an a-rank 80 or event so
what's next on our list o season 5 and
the creation of everyone's favorite
purple block of
chef Kevin the cube I'm splitting
Kevin's life into two separate live
events from season five and season six
this one is all about Kevin being
created moving around the map and the
kamikaze dive into loot lake this one
was a continuous event which lasted
about four years I think well at least
it felt like that in game the first part
was majestic an anomaly slowly uncovered
in the seasons new desert biome where
periodically a group of cacti were hit
by Thunderbolts and lightning it was
very very frightening me then the moment
happened without warning Kevin was born
I think it has an extra impact on me as
I was in game at that very moment trying
to take over tilted towers stopping to
see what on earth that sound was so far
away and as this was unannounced many
people completely missed this well our
Kevin began to roll and slowly made his
way all the way to loot Lake and another
event started he rolled into the water I
got to admit it I did like it but when
it was finished and the water was just
bouncy I was a little let down how'd you
feel about it the creation was so unique
the rolling cube was so much fun to use
in game and the way he dissolved was
pretty epic - this is gonna be tough I'm
gonna laugh tough I'm gonna go with the
B rating for this a very good but not
top of the class I also like that
fortnight added a memorial for his birth
and death place attention to detail is
awesome gotta love it on to season six
now the fought nightmares season
remember that one which saw Kevin rise
from the ashes of loot Lake and carry a
house around the island for the entire
season
explaining this to people who didn't
play fort night was so weird this was
also the time when we had about five
days of zombie action in game 2 this was
the season which was the end of Kevin
and right at the end of the season
the event happened and it absolutely
changed fortnight for people like me as
it added context and law and it made
Story theories a huge part of the
community once the floating island
visited all the rune spots on the island
it returned home to its loot lake
origins
and this is the time we said goodbye to
Kevin we watched him spin out of control
faster and faster until he exploded but
that explosion took us somewhere we'd
never been before another dimension
within fortnight we could see everyone
in the lobby with us and slowly we
learned that time travel is real
signified by the moment we saw the
butterfly honestly I'm getting goose
bumps remembering how great this was to
be a part of and on top of that the
event had an impact on the world with
loot lake becoming this stonehenge of
kevin the cube oh and the rainbow - that
was such a class touch so where shall we
put this on the list the impact of Kevin
you know one is going for this I am
throwing this in top spot better than
perfect better than an a-rank
this is s this is special tier it
deserves to be up there s rank where
would you put it
it's s tier right I'll be sure to stock
in the comments and reply outta nowhere
next events
[Music]
oh the Christmas season remember the
snow biome smashing into the island and
destroying flush Factory and introducing
many new spots like happy Hamlet this
was the season which gave us a huge Ice
Mountain called polar peak which is
important later but first the official
live event of the season can you
remember it
a frozen orb was spotted over the
melting snow around the castle and
inside the OP was the Ice King
later the countdown was added and we all
thought this was going to be monumental
and well if I'm honest this was really
rubbish I was totally unfulfilled by it
how did you feel the Ice King grew to
around 500 feet in size and through a
sheet of ice over the entire island the
snow biome took over the entire world
I struggled to find anyone who enjoyed
this event but hopefully it was you you
liked it did you what about the fiends
and the cube zombie things they came
back to I was so unhappy at the time
that I stopped playing for about two
weeks
I wonder how everyone else felt so I'm
sorry to do this but this is not going
to get a high mark it's not even a
c-grade in my eyes what I'm thinking
right now is is an e or an F of Zed but
the animation was great and the way the
the map changed was a WoW moment so I'll
be kind I'm going to make this a D rank
it was simply okay but not worth logging
in for in my ice where'd you put it on
your list well let's stay in Season
seven because it actually have three
live events if I remember correctly
although the next one is the smallest as
we reached New Year and we saw fortnight
celebrate it for 30 seconds
it could happen mid-march you could be
mid-battle and be forced to stop and
start dancing around for a while quite
funny the first few times but the
problem was everywhere in the world has
a different time zone and celebrates at
different times so we went through this
around 40 times it was very painful
I went from loving this to absolutely
hating it three hours later it became
tedious and frustrating and twelve
months later it happened again by the
way I don't know if I have any footage
of the original event so I'll likely put
in this year's New Year's
instead well if I'm honest I like it but
I didn't like it from a battle while
you're out perspective so I'm gonna put
this lower than the Ice King this is an
event for me but let's take that frown
and turn it upside down because this led
onto a huge live event massive you may
say a guy with a white bucket on his
head suddenly arrived at pleasant park
and press play on his decks
okay I'm under selling this a little
marshmallow arrived in hot night it was
another groundbreaking event from
fortnight and it was completely live
marshmallow was chatting to the crowd in
real time I'm gonna have to replace all
music here for copyright reasons but to
have a legitimate musical artist in
fortnight was brain melting and I
personally didn't expect to like his
music and they ended up loving it during
the event the animations were a bit
weird because we wanted 100 people to
see the concert together
so everything lost a little bit of
visual fidelity well at least on console
I'm sure it was great on PC good old PC
master-race but here's the game changer
the event kept growing until we were
bouncing around and seeing a flying
marshmallow man shooting around the
island the light show was epic no no pun
intended so where would you put this is
this as good as the butterfly event and
deserve that Estia rank or as this is
not related to the story and the
progression of the game would this be a
lesson mark I'm gonna give this an
a-rank truly brilliant event that showed
us the potential of fortnight's becoming
more than just simply battle royale
without this moment Travis Scott may
have never crashed landed in chapter 2
so thank you bucket head man let's go
forward another season in Chapter 1
season 8 season 8 this season was the
the volcano which randomly appeared on
the island at the start destroying my
favorite landing spot in whaling woods
rip the dream we also got pirates this
season and hidden buried treasure by the
end of the season a vault had been
uncovered at loot Lake under the Kevin
Stonehenge and it started to open well
not for me because nothing happened at
all in my game and nothing happened for
almost 40% of the community this was a
broken event for too many people in my
eyes or maybe I'm just completely
jealous don't judge me or hey well I got
a replay file shortly after so I was
still able to see the event and it was
great first we saw the vault open up and
we all went inside in there was a huge
doll
and a desk with so many hints to the
following season I loved it
here's something new that was introduced
we were all able to vote to bring back a
weapon that was vaulted I think the
reason I loved it so much was that the
community chose to bring back the drum
gun and all the sweaty streamers were
crying about it our happy days it was
fantastic other time I wanted epoch to
notice that streamers and they're
complaining doesn't represent the
majority of players so player agency and
players making decisions for such a cool
thing to add well that wasn't the end
you know after returning to our world we
saw the volcano shoot its load and hit
numerous locations retail row smashed
tilted towers demolished except for the
insurance building haha great touch for
tonight and even the ice mounting was
hit and began to crack this was all
phenomenal so now we have to put this in
the tier list oh I'm not sure about this
in my eyes this should be s rank but as
it didn't work for such a huge amount of
the people playing I'm gonna put this as
a solid a tier unforgettable and
impactful and yeah a little broken but
still epic what's next we're up to
season 9 this was the season where we
went into the future man great memories
tilted upgraded and the mobility in the
game was off the hook
we even had John Wick's how sad it I
really enjoyed this season and the live
event was unreal over the season we saw
the cracked mountain at polar peak
breakaway and suddenly a huge monster
escaped and began to swim around the
island at this time the volcano had
become a power plant and slowly made a
freaking great MechWarrior thing to
prepare for attack from that polar peak
monster the mech brought back memories
of Voltron and Power Rangers and all
that 90s and 80s goodness and then it
happened a beast of an event the monster
attacked and made a run for our vault
attempting to break it open
watching the robots bring into life and
come to the rescue was so impressive
using rockets and even dunking the
monster in the sea when the mech did his
badass walk back onto the island I was
done I was happy with that to be the end
of the event but he'll know far more to
come
monster jumped out and ripped off the
mechs arm leading to the mech being
forced to break open the vault it tried
so hard to protect Oh in the moment
where the statue in Tilton became a
swords oh man these memories it was so
good and in the end the mech saved the
island and vanished into the atmosphere
flying into space on the ground our
island was changed to with a destroyed
building and missing elements in tilted
and of course the monster skeleton
laying lifeless as a constant reminder
oh and also a note about the music in
that event it was so far beyond what
fortnight has ever done before I loved
it so much I think you can tell how much
I loved it but how much I'm ranting
about it and it all ended with the nexus
point being revealed perfection I'm not
messing around here this is esthe here
it's so good by far my favourite event
ever in fortnight or do you say am i
going over the top or was the final
battle the greatest thing you've ever
seen with your eyeballs let me know in
the comments please and finally the last
season in Chapter 1 season 10 or should
I say season X it was the season which
brought us the mechs in game okay that
that received a lot of hate but it
happened it was the season that saw rift
beacons added and areas the map changed
every single week Gotham City was in
this season
wow how far has this game come we saw
dusty Depot Depot however you say it
returned and the visitor came back to
build the rocket from all those seasons
ago he was thick by the way not sure why
that matters but I feel it does hashtag
katifaq over the season the nexus point
became unstable and after finding
cassette tapes we heard about the 7 an
intergalactic science force with unknown
origins and agendas when the day came we
all huddled around the rocket and
watched a time-traveling master class
from multiple dimensions rifting
together and descending upon that nexus
point the big moment came when the Nexus
was destroyed creating a black hole
which sucked us all into the unknown
probably the greatest and most confident
thing epic games did here was shut down
the game for days all we could do was
watch a black
Cole I remember watching some kids
thinking the game was legitimately gone
forever
those with good memories as we all know
chapter 2 began shortly after that so
now's the time to decide how great was
this event
it's another tough one isn't it noises
are you I don't think it's sto I don't
think this is as good as the final
battle or the butterfly event so this is
not an s for me the one thing I disliked
was that nobody actually saw the Nexus
changing because we were all looking the
wrong way we were all looking at the
Rockettes near the factories when
something was happening the other way
and we don't have replay files to check
what was happening very frustrating sir
dammit this is hard
I'm gonna go with the B this is a be
ranking for me very impressive event but
not the best in my eyes I wonder how
many people have triggered saying this
is only a be event so here's my final
list what do you think
am i speaking the truth or am i
completely delusional I'm honestly
really excited to see your thoughts in
the comments what was the greatest sport
night event in history and which were
the events which made you go oh okay and
also where would you put Travis Scott's
event from chapter 2 into this list yeah
that's an interesting thing to know I
really hope chapter 2 story events keep
improving upon season ones because I
adore what they do to the community they
bring us all together it's so damn good
on screen now are the good old coded
Amaru legends thank you so much for
using my code you're awesome to me I
salute you thanks right I'll be back
later this week this has been fun I hope
you enjoyed it too I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade I'll see you next
time
[Music]